wie sind sie denn jetzt war es ja
mehrfach erlebt ich glaube du sagst beim
abendessen auch schon mal neben der
queen
was können wir erforschen wie sind sie
so viel lachen ich glaub da müssen wir
eine sondersendung dazu machen also war
was kann ich über die erzählen in der
nussschale die kamera ist so sympathisch
dieser camilla ist jemand der nicht so
rüber ersten ein total gestehe ich weil
sie ist nicht so ein mensch der in der
öffentlichkeit wirkt wenn du dir wenn du
mit der persönlich bis erstmals ist sie
voller humor nicht so der typ
schmutziger gummistiefel sie ist ja der
typ hat wie du hast du das gefühl da ist
immer vier nasse labradore um sehr
wundern wenn du ins haus rein kommst
dann stehen dann erstmal so 10
schmutzige gummistiefeln und sie ist so
sie ist nun wirklich so sehr naturnahe
rustikaler lustiger lustiger typ der am
liebsten gummistiefel und eine
bomberjacke anhalt und draußen auf dem
land ist dieses ganze in der
öffentlichkeit war nämlich wenn sie dann
so nach berlin kommt und dann muss sie
dort sozusagen offiziell eine funktion
erfüllen das liegt dir gar nicht charles
er eher im gegenteil charles liebt so
dass auch das hof- und das formelle und
einen staatsbesuch machen und so weiter
dass das link dem sehr reden halten also
will ich freue mich richtig auf seine
rede im bundestag den einer draufkommen
verlassen
charles redet nie banalitäten also jede
rede von ihm ist interessant und er
lässt sich auch nicht schreiben sondern
er schreibt sie selber in seiner ganz
komischen schriftlich könnte müsste ich
die schrift mahnschreiben er schreibt
immer mit füller und denen die krieg
jedes jahr eine weihnachtskarte von
nuclear und diese schöne ist er nimmt
sich npd die schrift es geht so in allen
über er schreibt ohne im fülle auch zu
überstehen so viele schreibt dass er
wird sich wieder gelohnt auftreten
beschreibt dann so in einem durch und
und so schreibt er dann auch seine reden
und was ja viele gar nicht so oder
wissen oder vergessen haben es ist ja
ein dass echte erste grüne eins der
ersten grünen dies gab der hat schon von
ökologie geredet da war al gore der für
später den nobelpreis bekommen noch gar
nicht geboren also der war der war der
hat schon mit der hat er wurde früher
immer dafür
verarscht jetzt hier richter am käse
aber früher wurde der dicke kohle wurde
er dafür veranstalten mit pflanzen redet
weil er weil er natürlich absoluter öko
oder so man schon grün wenn man aber in
dem wie gesagt also dass der war er hat
organ hat einen eigenen bauernhof
riesige ländern ein hat schon mit
organischen organischen und bio und ohne
ohne chemische spritzmittel schon vor 40
jahren experimentiert heute findest du
in jedem also in berlin
konntest du dich eine straße und kommst
an ein angebot in dem fünf bio läden
vorbei ob zehn metern das war der hat
schon biobio gegessen als wir alle nur
als er als wir noch alle noch kimi
gefüttert haben